parla campagnaro se mi è venuto in
questo nuovo video di dio che brutta
facile chiamavo mica pista cioè la
capacità di osservazione di un'anatra
con che ragazzi erano arrivati che ero
per i venti devono sbloccare i livelli
successivi era arrivato a un certo punto
che stava diventando molto più difficile
che questo si muove tutto nell'anno
problema è che non si capisce con quale
fisica zii con quale fisica non è quello
il problema il problema è che devo
arrivare alla fine e la mamma eva black
hawk è i
ok vai vai vai bye bye bye bye bye
perfetto devo capire ragazzi se riesco
presto ma cos'è ma cosa fa perché a
lazio e ripigliati per cortesia ecco
bravo trani questi davis fonda bravo che
è difficile perché mi incassano nelle
cose che ancora non ho capito che ci del
cibo per cani mi sembra le giostre
quelle dove andavo da piccolo io c'è
solo un po più pericolose vabbè questo
si era notato lista come ho fatto a
oltrepassare il look e bug ragazzi
qualcuno mi deve spiegare perché sono
finito qui come sono finito qui ma sono
incastrato col pene non fatemi capire
c'è un problema di fondo sono incastrati
smo non vi fa muovere oggi è perfetto
ragazzi ci siamo il problema è che non
ho ancora una gamba qui devo andare
avanti senza il capo teca potrebbe
essere difficile per questo motivo ho
fatto dai vai vai vai vai vai no nord
c'è la coordinazione di un box un
incredibile però è papà e zio però
almeno saltare almeno quello fra te ti
prego ma posso lanciare io la mia testa
la finta così beh oddio oddio brega cosa
ho fatto
cosa fanno si arriva alla fine così
voglio un oscar tipo sarebbe stato
veramente straw hat certo ma dove sono
ma cos'è sta roba perfetto grazie
attento che c'è un buco c'è star buco
perfetto ora che era arrivato alla fine
io facevo un salto decente ma mai nella
vita
si possono così che danno al sushi a noi
la pancia di poli guardi quelle di poi
il poker è la francia sua attaccata
dallo sfili sono sono vivo con la
prateria per arrivare al check point ma
so già che succede qualcosa
ho vinto ma ragazzi non mi sembrano dei
degli assorbenti sti cosi aveva la forma
dell'assorbente ragazze vi faccio una
domanda rivolta proprio alle donne in sè
per sè ma ma gli assorbenti quando
vengono usati ci hanno più sangue di
questo gli capita di trovare dei pezzi
di gamba nei negli assorbendo io spero
per vogliono per l'amor di di eco
rimanendo in tema queste invece sono le
palle però ecco in questo caso si sono
rotte madonna che botta in faccia eva
[Musica]
papà e zio tanto sei già rincoglionito
di massa ne avete voglia di lanciarmi
un'altra palla è che il [ __ ] devo
guardarmi indietro perché sono crepe che
se continua a correre così prima o poi
sarebbe con burrone non lo vedo e cado
giù quindi effetto non ci ho lasciato la
testa non fermi di ditte c'è un replay
datemi un replay non so come ho fatto
maurito va bene così e poli vaghe
chiunque tu sia ecco bravo e super
efficace possa lanciare sta cosa
bello ottimo sono più indietro di
contano prima perfetto dove stiamo
andando
ma salve a devo entrare potrebbe sì lo
posso buttarmi che morbido grazie che
bello ma ci avete un pandoro di sotto se
non ce l'ho nel culo e dove non c'era il
pandoro ragazzi pazienza posso lanciare
la testa la juicy bravo bravo 10 su 10
ora vedo il traguardo perfetto provo a
fare una cosa ragazzi non so quanto
possa funzionare ma ci provo terminati
ok
l'esma wengè gary locke perfetto
perfetto minchia che mira piano piano si
fa chi è ha senso se si mette per la
prima volta la fisica in questo gioco ha
un senso che botta
non stavo scherzando come non stavo
scherzando stavo dove sono finite
impossibile posso ancora fare ecco l'ho
già fatta ci ha fatto acqua perfetto ci
ha messo anni per falso roba ma ok a
posto perfetto grazie bella ciao jolo
ho vinto tratto sono uscito anche a fare
un punteggio della madonna banche al
terzo di oggi che sarebbe ragazzi quella
non l'avete mai vista ma io lo so e
l'entrata di una vagina
siamo dentro una vagina stay in della se
vi devo stuprare la nonna ditelo subito
stai nella luce a perché se non sono
nella luce salto in aria tipo prima
state proci però ci prova se ce l'ho
fatta sono affatto dio
ma dire che si va da ragazzina e sta
cosa è un'ansia ve lo dico anche qua
devo stare nella luce e no quando posso
fare quello che voglio
qui posso arrivare anche lì jolo no ma
come cazzo è possibile non vedono o non
ci voglio non ci volevo credere
ma veramente non sono proprio un fan del
cibo per cani e preparò le devo arrivare
fin laggiù ma perché conquistare
babilonia era un'impresa più semplice li
mortacci tua sorella putrefatta perché
astuccio la l'ansia ma manco all'esame
di maturità circostanze ok
hanno preso ma dai di idiota che se
quella roba lì ce l'ho fatta
quest'estate si muoia adesso no vabbè
potevo veramente rompere il scassare il
monitor ucci delle famiglie perfetto
ragazzo ho fatto è stato è stato un
parto digiuno level compie ma perché
riesce bloccato a mia mi servono 120
cose mi chiama ci manca solo quello
guarda layer 3 all asia perfetto
perfetto bello già sono un partito da
dire non è male ragazzi problemi che
faccio schifo io schivare i laser come
non detto
sono ancora vivo con la testa oddio no
nicchia forza di gravità del cazzo il
piano inclinato la merda che ho studiato
in fisica però ce l'ho fatta attenzione
non so come ma ce l'ho fatta
è un gradino frate un gradino bravo
bravo tom incazzarmi seriamente questa
roba sta diventando veramente incasinato
però però però orcal h si è fatta non ci
credo perfetto calcoli riesco a farli
senza morire manca una volta non so
neanche io come passo dall'impossibile
al farlo in un secondo senza motivo
guardarli arrivato al traguardo finito
seriamente zio e siamo arrivati
all'ultimo ragazzi poi devo fare anche
questo in teoria per da sbloccare 120 e
tutto in caduta no che figo tipo fallin
fredda era un giochino che giocavo io
sull'iphone no vabbè che figata
ma è un dentista e me pensavo anche un
oculista e in teoria uno verso cos'è
cosa vuoi dalla mia ad arrivare al suo
pronto a saltare fratesi sbagli a
saltare ti ammazzo io dove cazzo sono
perché sono è giusto cioè in teoria è
giusto dovevo andare qua veramente no
fermi no non ci credo mai non ci credo
mai i temi che riesco ad arrivarci vi
prego no era arrivata alla fine senza
neanche poi c'è ho pagato tutto ragazzi
sta parte la parte più diffusa è non
prendere troppo alla lettera quello che
devo entrare in quel buco
questa frase non fraintendete per carità
ci siamo
oddio ben ascoltami canoa ascolta porca
eva non ci ha però mai aprendo il suo
ragazzo
il possibile ce l'ha fatta comunque 12
minuti per fare questo ragazzi ci ho
messo una vita a nava beh l'importante è
avercela fatta perché ora ragazzi ma che
vai allora in teoria ma questo qua va
sbloccato con 120 scatolette neo 108 è
il prossimo episodio prima di continuare
voglio provare a vedere che cos'è sta
roba che mi sembra abbastanza figo
perché se si sblocca così però ragazzi
nel prossimo episodio cosa sento subito
piaciuto documento è un mi piace anche a
face di facebook e come grillo stata
l'edizione se quest'estate non ci
vediamo al prossimo vi bellavia
[Musica]